so here's his new unit circle a new
angle here okay now you've got your axes
they're labeled now you can go ahead and
put in your calculator just like we did
when we were all graphing right you
could put into your calculator sine 150
and it won't give you an answer okay but
let's see if we can anticipate the
answer and confirm with your calculator
and participate by this definition okay
so that's 150 degrees right I've gone
all the way over to this part over here
you're and I said I call these quadrants
okay we started over here in the top
right where everything's positive and
since we start there we call this like I
mentioned before the first quadrant okay
I am measuring anti-clockwise which is a
bit funny I mean losing reverse but if
that's the first one that makes this guy
the second quadrant okay third and
fourth
okay now what can we know about what's
sine of 150 is just by looking at this
okay
remembering that the highest this circle
goes is 1 right and I've got an x
coordinate negative 1 over there
you can see whatever sine 150 years
whatever sine hundred 50 years since
it's the y-coordinate it's going to be
between some somewhere between zero one
do you agree with that like I didn't
know exactly where it is yet okay but I
know it's got to be somewhere in there
right so do you remember when we drew
our values from zero to 90 degrees it
went up and went up and went up I'm
trying to imagine what happens there's
90 at 120 10 20 30 40 50 I'm trying to
imagine what happens over here now all
the parts that we drew they were going
up right they were going up so it
doesn't seem that unreasonable certain
thing it's just gonna keep going up
right but look this y-coordinate as I go
around the circle it doesn't keep going
up forever
the y-coordinate comes back down do you
see that so in some way between naught M
1 okay now have a look at this with me
before you go and punch it into your
calculator because it's circle it's a
very symmetrical shape right very very
symmetrical actually it's just about the
most symmetrical shape in existence okay
so therefore I want to take what I know
from over here cuz I know what happens
over here because you punched all those
numbers in your calculator from 0 to 90
I want to take what happened to you and
bring it over okay so if I flip this guy
like just horizontally around over the
y-axis right it's gonna look like this
do you agree okay so I just flipped it
on okay now tell me some symmetry here
I've got a straight line so this is 150
degrees what this small angle in here
it's gonna be 30 right because angles on
a straight line add up to 180
so five thirty here and this thing is
symmetrical what's this angle over here
sadi just this little one
okay now pull in a second we know what
size daddy is right we know what side 30
is it's a half right so that should be
this y-coordinate over here it should be
something
aha do you agree with that right sine is
the y-coordinate and in fact you can
kind of see if you go up and you measure
and you can even grab a protractor in a
second if you measure 30 degrees and you
draw it over here you should actually be
able to measure this exactly halfway
between zero and one
right can I hold on a second it's
symmetrical you're really sick of me
saying symmetrical right so this is 1/2
and that's the y-value what's the Y
value over here Y value is vertical okay
now this is the same vertically as this
spot over here
do you agree vertically that going up
going up this little distance so it
should also be a half it'll be negative
if I was looking at the X values right
what are the X values because you
remember you told me before the X values
for cause does anyone remember what cuz
there it is it's actually on the board
it's yeah it's gonna be zero point eight
seven right it's gonna be rid three on
two
this is an x value so when I flip over
to this side this is the positive side
and that's the negative sign for X so
this would be minus root 3 on 2 okay now
this is what we are guessing off of the
unit circle get your calculator out now
and pop in side of a hundred and fifty
degrees okay and magically lo and behold
zero point five okay did you get it no
your calculator isn't telling you the
answer the calculator is telling you
this right because it knows what to look
for and so that's how it's gotten it's
not true the process we just went to
right it's just memorizing that's all
you can go ahead as well if your Y and
you can
you can check in close buddy you should
get 0.87 right does that make sense you
see a bit now go ahead and put in cause
150 which is over this side you should
get exactly the same number because it's
symmetrical but this should be a minus
sign in the front right of course is a
minus sign because I've gone over that
side of the circle okay all right
think for a second let's see if I can
push this a little bit further I flip
down from here to here right if I flip
from here down okay now first you can
tell me the coordinates of this thing
right I'll call this R yes
what's the x-coordinate it's gonna be
the same as this right it's just the
down negative root three on two
okay but because I'm underneath the axis
now the Y values negative isn't it right
so should be - uh-huh
so that's cause of some angle that's
sine of some angle what's the angle
butcher what is the size of that angle
remember I'm measuring from the positive
x-axis so I'm gonna stop all the way my
black someone take my black
stuff for me and I'm gonna go all the
way around what is that angle remember
there's loads of symmetry in here don't
forget this is this is 13 here's up it's
gonna be 210 weighted 210 come from how
did you get 210
very good you go all the way around to
the opposite side that's 180 and then
you go a little further 30 degrees okay
so you go ahead
you've got your calculator there put in
sign 210 does it give you what we were
expecting yeah it did better otherwise
go get your calculator training because
it's definitely negative 1/2 you can do
cause if you want right I think you
trust me now you don't need to reach me
calculator let's do one more right
because I've said this way that way I'm
gonna go
okay - first tell me the coordinates for
this s tell me the coordinates
it's going to be the same as this one
first for the x-coordinate
but the y-coordinate will be the same as
this one because it's vertical it's
below the axes - a hump okay what angle
is that going to be remember you've got
thirty degrees in here one more time
what would it be if I went all the way
around the circle and came back to the
beginning what angle would that be 360
that's a revolution right but I don't go
all the way around
I go all the win then I stop that angle
I'm short on it
so therefore me 360 take away that which
is 330 right now now you can know you
don't need to reach for your calculator
right sine 330 it's going to be this cos
330 kind of it is that's what sign is
that's our new definition now this is
really powerful and finally he's he's
the whole point of this right do you
remember a couple lessons ago I told you
sign meant something like it's got a
name for a reason remember what sign
means I've got one who knows sinus right
remember I told you what sign actually
made I'm gonna show you sure for me one
last set of axes this one will be
different to the ones we drew before I'd
like it to look like this so I just have
the right-hand side as it were now see
how we were all this way we were
comparing sign this sign this sign this
okay
and we had a whole bunch of different
values now you already know what sine X
looks like you already know what it
looks like from nought to 90 right it
looks roughly like this that's what the
part that we drew earlier was okay so if
that's where it goes from naught to 90
I've just I just plugged in all these
values right that should go all the way
up to 360 degrees
okay so there's 90 there's 180 270
three-sixty now let's put in these
angles that you just told me okay we've
already got all the ones from not
tonight
great okay this one was 150 150 degrees
so that's sort of around here right it's
me uh-huh there it is some somewhere
about here the next one you told me was
210 degrees and it was negative 1/2
negative 1/2 hmm 200 cakes back here
roughly then you told me 300 say degrees
and that was they devour ok now I have
some dots before I join them I'm gonna
need 1 2 3 more dots to joiner then I
think we'll have enough information ok
180 270 360 these are really important
and you can read them right off this
diagram okay
remember I'm looking for the y
coordinate my toilet
where's hundred eighty degrees it's all
the way here
what's the y coordinate of that point
there just the y coordinate it's zero
isn't it's on the axis not up or down
it's zero okay zero right there 270 from
here all the way around down to Leo
what's the y-coordinate you they would
addition its negative one right 270
degrees last one 360 you went all the
way around you're actually where you
started what's the microwave hold on
y-coordinate it's zero is it cuz I'm on
the axis zero okay ready to join the
dots here we go
this is what we call the sine curve
which is a bit like saying ATM machine
because you know how ATM machine is an M
amazing machine right the would sign
sign it means curved that's what sign
means that's why you have a sinus it's
this curved part inside your nasal
passage right this sign graph if you
look at all the values it's this curvy
thing right a bit of a spoiler for
Thursday you keep going because the
circle just goes round and round and
round and round you just get the same
thing over and over and I've just
destroyed my love but you get the idea
right it keeps on and curbing so this
huge new idea we've just explored it for
same unit-sample we're gonna exploit for
it
cosine and tan on Thursday